bien donc rapidement on a mis en place
ce matin notre comité de campagne avec
une une équipe qui est à la fois
concentré autour no2 de chefs de nos
deux familles politiques donc la
direction exécutive des républicains au
tour de bernard accoyer
la direction de l'ugtt et y autour de
jean-christophe lagarde
on y associe également les les
présidents des grandes associations
d'élus c'est à dire les maires de france
les départements les régions
l'ancien comité de campagne donc avec
nous anciens candidats à la primaire ou
leurs représentants les présidents des
groupes parlementaires
les vice-présidents de de l'assemblée
bon ce qu'il doit faire une équipe
entre 30 et 40 personnes qui permet à la
fois d'avoir une représentation là la
plus large des différentes sensibilités
qui puisse y avoir mais surtout des gens
qui ont à la fois une expérience et puis
une implantation locale qui permet de
bien travailler pour préparer cette
campagne également une équipe de
porte-parole avec florence portelli
damien abad david lisnard
philippe vigier catherine vautrin franck
proust philippe cochet donc il aurait
aussi sousse est je crois la ligne est
simple pour nous elle vient d'être
évoquée par par françois par bernard et
part et par jean-christophe nous sommes
en situation de pouvoir gagner ces
législatives et nous y allons clairement
pour gagner avec un atout qui est celui
de l'ancrage territorial de nos de nos
candidats au moment où en marché en
difficulté on voit bien pour pour ses
investitures et puis parallèlement cela
au moment aussi où on assiste à une
explosion au moins deux grandes
difficultés au sein de l'appareil
l'appareil front national nous nous
avons un projet
qui nous rassemble qui a tenu compte du
des résultats du premier tour eric va
vous le vous le présenter dans un
instant donc cette campagne se fait à la
fois sur des terrains sur des candidats
qui ont une implantation de terrain donc
campagne de proximité avec un large
déploiement de tous nos orateurs nos
orateurs nationaux parallèlement à cela
on va là rythmé avec des grands meetings
régionaux le lancement on va vraiment
être le 20 mars le vin le 20 mai au parc
au parc floral et nous allons faire dans
chacune des régions des grands meetings
régionaux mais ensuite se démultiplier
effectivement sur l'ensemble des
circonscriptions
l'autre point important c'est qu'une
campagne elle doit être incarnée et nous
avons un chef de file qui l'incarnent
c'est à dire que les français ont bien
reçu ce message c'est que nous voulons
être en situation d'avoir la majorité
demain et donc de l'exercer de pouvoir
gouverner avec un premier ministre qui
serait françois baroin si nous avons
effectivement la majorité et je pense
que entre la proximité la campagne de
terrain de nos candidats la manière dont
françois baroin incarne notre notre
projet au niveau national et bien les
quand les conditions sont réunies pour
pour faire le meilleur résultat possible
les meilleurs résultats possibles c'est
d'être majoritaire le 18 juin